it's going out to chris van cleave in
louisville kentucky at one of the key
hubs for the massive coordinated
shipping effort involving ups
and fedex chris good morning to you
well good morning i can tell you that
some deliveries have already
started on the east coast and we're
talking about delivering hope there is
plenty of room for hope on board this
747 freighter
it's the type of airplane that will be
carrying some of this vaccine
all over the country right alongside
your online shopping and your christmas
gifts for the vaccines that are being
delivered today
across america they started their
journey less than 24 hours ago
in kalamazoo michigan
cheers of relief sent off the very first
shipment of pfizer's coronavirus vaccine
as it left the company's michigan plant
under
public started by semi and continued by
air today we shipped 500 000 doses by
the end of the week will have
up to 2.9 million doses distributed in
the us
ups flight 3477 carried roughly half of
those first doses for americans
touching down at the company's
louisville hub with captain houston
mills at the controls
do you feel like you were delivering
hope this morning absolutely they know
it's going to make a meaningful
difference in the lives of so many
the approximately 75 specially designed
cold boxes
each carrying 50 pounds of dry ice and
20 pounds of vaccine
have gps and temperature tracking as the
vials have to be kept at negative 94
degrees
moving through 155 miles of conveyor
belts at ups world port
the vaccine is sorted and loaded on
planes bound for more than 30 cities
with deliveries starting around 8 30
this morning
the entire logistics effort is being
tracked in real time inside the
company's
covet command center are these the most
important shipments
you guys have ever moved absolutely in
my opinion yes
wes wheeler is the president of ups
healthcare it gets on the plane first it
gets off the plane first
the drivers and the pilots both know
that they're carrying vaccines
to speed deliveries the country has been
divided between ups and fedex with
vaccines going to all 50 states and u.s
territories as far as guam
fedex is also delivering its first batch
of vaccine today
this is going to be one of the most
challenging public health distribution
efforts we've seen
it's going to be hard to imagine this
going off without a hitch that there
likely are unanticipated issues that are
going to arise when you're shipping that
many vaccine doses all around the
country
fedex tells us it has already made its
first vaccine delivery
on the east coast we expect to see many
more as the morning goes on as that
priority overnight starts being
delivered
all over the u.s we know here in
louisville a hospital is going to
receive
its shipment somewhere in the next
couple of hours they expect to begin
vaccinating healthcare workers about an
hour
after it arrives at the hospital anthony
amazing operation chris thank you